et aujourd'hui ça soit sur l'hydrogène
que ça soit sur l'hybride la technologie
n'est pas encore au point et les camps
ce qu'à ses balbutiements
donc aujourd'hui ça va arriver tous les
nouveaux engins on investit dans de
nouveaux engins qui consomment de moins
en moins donc on fait des efforts mais
aujourd'hui faut nous laisser le temps
faut laisser le temps la technologie
d'arrivée et puis ensuite on trouvera
des solutions et on fera des efforts
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment sûr sur
cette soudaineté de cette mesure qui
nous pénalisent est énormément donc
cette mesure oui pendant six mois qu'est
ce qui va se passer parce que moi
aujourd'hui je pense que les vingt six
mois pour discuter pour voir les
modalités
et puis après bien pour qu'on explique
aussi à notre chant ty notre métier ce
qu'on peut mettre en place et puis après
maints pouvoir comment comment tous
ensemble on peut avancer et puis de
verdir notre travail est de travailler
de mieux en mieux et dont on est bien
conscient qu'aujourd'hui l'écologie est
vraiment au coeur de toutes les
préoccupations mais faut laisser à tout
le monde le temps de s'adapter parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas s'adapter du
jour de landes au lendemain on est dans
des entreprises on a des budgets
prévisionnels on anticipe des
investissements aujourd'hui faut nous
laisser le temps d'anticiper tout ça
pour pouvoir être efficace et pour
pouvoir de moins en moins consommé 2
des zones